- I have to start with this.
So, you gave a tour of
your house, recently
and mentioned a mommy juice wall.
- Oh, God.
- [Kelly] Which I'm into and I own.
(Tia laughs)
- Yeah so, MTV Cribs,
they came to my house
and I was showcasing my wall of wine.
And my son, I have a ten-year-old
and he was actually doing
the interview with me
and he called me out.
He said, "Mom, Mom, you got to,
you got to tell them,
you know, what happened".
I'm like, "What are you talking about?"
And he was like, "Remember,
last night you drank
the whole bottle of wine".
(audience and Kelly laughs)
- It's vitamins.
- I mean, but I call it like, mommy juice.
- [Kelly] Yeah, It's good for
your heart, that's what I say.
- It is, it's really great for your heart.
- Even healthcare workers are into it.
(audience applauds)
(Tia and Kelly laugh)
- [Tia] But, yeah.
- I love that your parent...
Our kids always out us,
in the most awesome scenarios.
- They always do, they're
honest, you know what I mean?
They're just honest people.
- [Kelly] Oh, they're
too honest, sometimes.
I'm like, "Okay, you
can't say that to people".
Like, other people.
But you love crime shows.
- I do, Oh my God.
- [Kelly] All my friends love crime shows.
I am terrified of them.
- [Tia] Really?
- Yes, because I was into it for a minute
and then all of a sudden,
I found myself just being paranoid.
I was like, "They're going to come in.
I know it's the third floor,
but they got in the third
floor in that one episode".
(woman laughs)
Like I start... So like,
what's the biggest crime
you ever personally, committed though?
Let's get really into it.
- Oh my gosh, okay you
guys, this is an exclusive.
So, my sister and I, you know,
we're kind of seen like, you
know, the perfect, you know,
twins and girls or whatever, but...
- [Kelly] Those are the ones you...
- Yeah, I know, but we were
actual cheaters, in school.
- [Woman] Good work.
- [Kelly] You know what? Way to be clever.
- You said good work.
(Tia laughs)
We would do, we would do this crazy thing
and I believe the teachers caught on,
because we couldn't sit next
to each other anymore, during like, exams.
So my sister, she was,
she would be in front of
me, I would be behind her.
And then, if she wanted to know
the answer to question number one,
and if it was like, multiple
choice, if it was like A,
I would just kind of tap her, like that,
once for A and then two
for B and three for C.
- Wow, now that's just clever.
- I mean.
(audience applauds)
Sorry, kids don't do that.
It's wrong, don't cheat.
- [Kelly] You know what though,
when your kids start to
do it, you can't talk.
(audience and Tia laugh)
You can't say anything.
Who else is going to confess to something?
Did you do something naughty?
- I was so, hoping you
weren't going to do that.
(audience laughs)
I'm just going to go...
- You can talk about it on daytime.
- I remember shoplifting
when I was like, 10.
- [Woman] I'm so glad
you... That's what I was...
- I got, there was like...
(audience laughs)
There was like a greeting
card in this store,
in the mall, that had a photo
that looked exactly like the family dog.
And I was just like, "No one will notice
if I just put this in my jacket".
And my parents got so
mad at me and I was like,
"I thought this was just a fun, like..."
But they went at me for it.
- You, okay...
(Kelly mumbles)
What you stole, was a greeting card?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah and by the way, though,
my parents were mad at me,
it is still on the refrigerator
at my parent's house.
(audience applauds)
- [Tia] Oh my God, that's hilarious.
- Wait, so you're not going to own one?
- Yeah, no, I just think,
I'm just generally quite, light-fingered.
(audience and guests laughs)
I call it, "Lovingly re-homing".
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- You know, don't steal from individuals.
Just like, you know, hotels.
- Oh, okay.
(audience laughs)
- You're like Ross on friends,
where he's like, "It's
free, it's in the room".
- Exactly, if it's not
screwed down, I'm having it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love it.